what's better being the man who sold the
world or the one who doomed it to
nuclear annihilation I'm Dave and
welcome to your GameSpot news update
konami has opened up a secret event in
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain it
can only be accessed when a special set
of conditions are met and thankfully
Konami has provided those very
instructions for everyone it's called
the secret nuclear disarmament event and
as its name suggests it involves getting
rid of lots of nuclear weapons too first
access the secret nuclear some event you
must have completed mission 31 you must
not own or currently be developing any
nuclear weapon if you have any nukes in
stock you must dismantle them certain
conditions relate to nuclear
proliferation must be met on a regional
server for your corresponding gaming
platform all nuclear weapons on your
regional server corresponding to your
console or platform must have been
dismantled in other words the amount of
nukes on your platform server must be
equal to zero meet all four conditions
and the disarmament event will be
triggered when you return to mother base
or complete a main mission konami
explained should new nukes be developed
after conditions three and four have
been filled this event can be repeated
by fulfilling all four conditions again
the official Metal Gear Twitter
regularly posts the number of nukes on
each platform currently listed as 188
for ps4 140 for ps3 52 for the xbox 135
to the Xbox 360 with Steam having the
humble amount of eleven thousand four
hundred and seventy three I guess PC
players don't want the world to be free
of nukes after all so will you be
striving towards nuclear disarmament are
you going to be the one troll who keeps
a nuke in his basement to spoil it for
all the other big bosses let us know in
the comments below or you can find me on
twitter at a regular Dave and for all
your gaming and entertainment news stay
tuned to games.com
you